[Musique]
un automne déjà compliquée et un hiver
qui peut être très difficile oui et à
l'hiver qui peut être traitée ici on
n'est pas en train de manipuler les gens
parlent and her la mortalité à part chez
les gens qui ont une très faible
espérance de vie est très faible comme
nous l'avons observé nous depuis le
début donc ça sert à rien de s'affoler
quand on prend un ton grave et quand on
dit qu'ils ne sont plus compliquées
c'est pas pour emmerder les gens c'est
pas pour se rendre intéressant c'est
juste parce qu'on a envie qu'ils se
protègent qu'on puisse les protéger et
israël devient le premier pays à imposer
un nouveau confinement total un
confinement nationale nous avons pris la
décision d'imposer un plan de re
confinement pour les trois prochaines
semaines avec la possibilité de le
prolonger mais pour l'instant nous avons
décidé de reconfirmer le pays à partir
de vendredi
c'est un scénario que je ne peux pas
envisager comme ministre de l'économie
parce qu'on voit bien le coup que ça
pour nos entreprises pour les
commerçants qui pour nous touche donc
tout cela des faits réels mais tout cela
dépend de nous car une eau du respect
des gestes-barrières du port du masque
d'autres comportements responsables
après sa victoire marseille s'embrase
partout dans la ville les supporters
euphoriques fait le succès de leur
équipe
et très vite le masque et les gestes
barrières sont pour certains oubliés
à la demande du premier ministre
plusieurs préfets dont celui des bouches
du rhône aura l'occasion pour l'occasion
sans doute de proposer au gouvernement
des mesures de restriction
supplémentaire pour pouvoir éviter des
rassemblements comme celui ci donc je
fais confiance également au préfet ce
nom de la jauge de cinq mille à mille
personnes sur la voie publique comme
dans les établissements recevant du
public
interdiction de la consommation debout
de même la consommation debout n'est pas
autorisée vous avez remarqué que s'est
encore fait remarquer que c'est encore
la faute de paris ils ont qu à bien
jouer cfoot est et bars ayez font pas la
fête sur le port aujourd'hui en réalité
mais s'est trompé en tout ça sera pas
grave pas plus grave qu'une grippette
les trottinettes le nombre de morts ces
saisonniers
sanem pas l'épée chaussée dans les états
les plus chauds les états unis où il ya
le plus de morts etc etc
c'est à dire que c'est excellent
collègue qui est vraiment été un
fonctionnel de très haut niveau par un
phénomène dans le détail de quelle je ne
peux pas rentrer a connu une évolution
qui mois son collègue ne peut qu être
atterré
la consommation d'alcool sur la voie
publique sera interdite après 20 heures
les soirées dansantes dans les eaux rp
sont interdites les soirées dansantes
dans les établissements recevant du
public seront également interdites
je regrette qu'on n'écoute pas ce que je
dis si vous voulez je regrette qu'il ya
eu une à mm pour leur m d'ici vire dans
tout le monde sait qu'il ne marche pas
et que théoriquement on empêche de
prescrire la ligue roc cyclo keane et
personnellement ça a un sens qui
m'échappe et tous les jours des
associations des parents des policiers
des élus locaux qui concrètement lutte
contre cette merde qu'est la barre dans
cette mer de la drogue c'est de la merde
quand j'étais gamin à la télévision dans
les années 80 il y avait un spot jeu pas
si vous vous rappelez la drogue c'est de
la merde mais ils luttent contre cette
merde on va pas légaliser cette merde il
ya peut-être un intérêt cynique pour ce
gouvernement là un moment où on va avoir
une cascade de plans sociaux de
mécontentement populaire très légitime
de crise économique a percuté la france
c'est plus simple d'interdire les
rassemblements pour sur l'eau sous motif
sanitaire d'interdire les manifestations
de mettre tout le monde sous masque que
de gérer le politiquement
démocratiquement comme on devrait le
faire un mouvement populaire sociale qui
risque d'être extrêmement puissant moi
je regrette que le ministre de la santé
soient pas venus voir comment ça marche
et ici comme ça il aurait pu prendre des
décisions qui permettrait de faire du
benchmarking
excusez moi pour ce terme anglais
c'est-à-dire du transfert de savoirs de
ici ailleurs plutôt que nous traiter
comme le vilain petit canard des
nageoires aux des yeux bleu clair et
surtout un pelage orange et ce bébé
phoque ou en fait partiellement albinos
a été découvert par un biologiste russe
qui le qualifie sur sa page instagram de
vilain petit canard
contrairement à l'histoire l'animal
n'est pas rejeté par sa mère qui le
nourrit bien mais le scientifique craint
que la communauté de phoques ne finisse
par l'ignorer à cause de sa différence